bonjour et bienvenue dans cette première
émission de 2014 nous sommes à
strasbourg au parlement européen
dans cette émission direction l'espagne
un pays qui pour attirer les
investisseurs leur propose un visa
longue durée pour qui investira plus de
500000 euros sur leur territoire son nom
le golden visa le visa en or mais
d'abord l'actualité les dirigeants
européens se sont félicités il ya
quelques semaines de l'adoption d'un
accord sur l'union bancaire mais à quoi
ça sert c'est la question de la semaine
fin décembre plus que quelques heures
avant la trêve des confiseurs là au
creux de la nuit une négociation
marathon et à la clé un ultime accord
les ministres des finances de la zone
euro a racheté un consensus sur l'union
bancaire et tous scandent à la
révolution
l'union bancaire ou plutôt un cadre
européen de résolution des faillites des
banques
l'idée est digne d'un slogan les banques
devront payer pour les banques les
établissements bancaires de la zone euro
devront donc abonder un fonds qui
permettra de renflouer leurs consoeurs
en difficulté à le citoyen n'aura donc
plus à venir au secours de la finance en
fait pas vraiment parce que ce fonds ne
sera opérationnel qu'à l'horizon 2025 et
les ministres ont accouché d'une
véritable usine à gaz que certains
estiment inquiétante
les négociations au parlement européen
s'annonce déjà longue et difficile
alors à quoi bon bancaire
à quoi sert l'union bancaire et ce
dispositif est il une usine à gaz
et bien pour répondre à ces questions
c'est les moins de notes qui m'a rejoint
sur ce plateau bonjour je vous ai député
européen membre du groupe socialiste est
maître de conférences en économie a pas
rien alors quand vous voyez on nous a
parlé de révolution
fin décembre c'était le plus grand pas
vers l'intégration européenne
est ce que est ce que c'est le cas c'est
une nouvelle révolution manquée ouais le
parlement européen avait pour sa part
fait des propositions extrêmement
ambitieuse union bancaire avec un
superviseur unique la banque centrale
européenne qui a des règles
prudentielles sur la base desquels il
l'a fait les tests des ratios de
solvabilité des ratios de liquidité voir
s'il est bon on a oui puisqu'on attend
aujourd'hui des directives issues de ce
qu'on appelle techniquement crd4 c'est à
dire des directives qui impose aux
banques des règles de solvabilité et des
règles de liquidité pour éviter quelques
et lequel ils ne prennent l'eau comme ça
a été le cas pendant la crise
et puis en cas de crise justement deux
fronts on avait proposé deux fonds un
fonds de garantie des dépôts pour éviter
l'épisode grec où on a taxé les dépôts
enfin on a essayé top et les dépôts des
petits épargnants et heureusement c'est
pas passé et puis le deuxième fonds
qu'on proposait c'est à fond de
résolution unique pour éviter que la
dette privée des banques ne se
transforme en dette publique qui pèse
ensuite sur le contribuable et et donne
lieu aux politiques d'austérité qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
bon mais là donc vous n'avez pas été
suivies finit là on n'a pas été suivi
c'est sur l'histoire du du fonds de
résolution des crises parce que les
allemands ne veulent pas parce que comme
david et comme d'habitude ils refusent
la solidarité parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas c'est que mutualisent à terme en
fait c'est ses passifs quoi des banques
oui il estime que
chacun doit payer pour sa paroisse voilà
que pas payer pour les autres
c'est ça c'est la position de la droite
allemande parce que martin schulz qui
est président du pop du parlement
européen quitte allemand lui jamais très
courageuse socialiste et il y là il a
dénoncé cet accord parce que justement
il n'allait pas assez loin sur le fonds
de résolution des crises et lui et le
plus fervent porte parole de la position
que je vous je vous explique aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs lors de ce conseil il avait
tout de suite dit que c'était un impact
presque dangereux
il avait eu des mots très très fort à ce
propos la les négociations démarrent
finalement qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
de la part du parlement européen sur
cette question est ce que la terre ne
risque pas de voir une fois de plus les
états venir au pot et sauver les banques
dans quelques années vu que ce fonds de
résolution qui sera abondé par les
banques n'est prévu que pour 2026 oui
mais le parlement européen est tout de
même en codécision donc c'est pas la
première fois qu'on voit que les états
passe au dessus du parlement européen
par d'android parce que le parlement
européen ait parfois complaisant parce
que ses députés subissent les pressions
des états nationaux
assure-toi d'élections électeurs afin d'
élections urbaines oui sauf que oui la
désignation des listes etc
vous pourrez y compris mais cela dit
formellement le parlement européen peut
prendre une position forte sur ce sujet
comme il a pu en prendre sur d'autres
sujets sur le budget par exemple
oui le sur le budget il a conduit les
états à revoir un petit peu leur copie
même si même si le parlement aurait
aurait aurait sans doute été plus
ambitieux si effectivement le la
question avait été sur la table un autre
moment qu'au moment de la désignation
sur les listes nous sommes d'accord et
bien justement en parlant de liste je
voulais qu'on réécoute un petit
événement politique qui s'est passé fin
décembre dernier on écoute tout de suite
et henry en plateau
je m'engage dans une nouvelle mission
j'ai pas l'impression de m'engager en
politique dans le sens où j'ai pas
programmé de faire une carrière
politique
j'ai simplement envie de continuer le
combat que nous menons depuis maintenant
plusieurs années notamment sur le
maintien de l'industrie en france en
europe et j'ai envie de le poursuivre à
un autre niveau au niveau européen parce
que c'est là où se prennent toutes les
grandes décisions à strasbourg et à
bruxelles exactement qui nous impacte et
moi qui suis salarié du groupe
arcelormittal qui est apportée dans dix
pays européens
je vois les décisions européennes
comment elle nous apparaît
du monde loc on a reconnu edouard martin
célèbre syndicaliste de florange qui a
donc pris la tête de l'istrie lui a
offert le parti socialiste dans le grand
est ici sur vos terres là où vous étiez
élu et vous n'avez pas été reconduits
sur sa liste quelle est votre lecture de
ces événements le problème c'est pas
edouard martin parce que le caractère
régional d'exister très formel le vrai
problème j'aurais pu candidats ailleurs
c'est pas le problème
vincent peillon est candidat dans le
sud-est il habite à paris bon c'est pas
le problème le vrai problème c'est un
problème politique
c'est que en france et la remarque ne
vaut pas seulement pour la gauche
la plupart des partis ont une approche
extrêmement intergouvernemental des
questions européennes
et quand ils sont au pouvoir par exemple
ils gèrent les affaires européennes
intergouvernementale en se
désintéressant de ce qui se passe au
parlement européen alors que si il avait
poussé leurs logiques pro-européenne
jusqu'au bout il ferait monter en
puissance justement le parlement
européen
l'exécutif s'appuierait sur le rapport
de forces que nous pouvons construire au
parlement européen pour engager un bras
de fer par exemple avec avec madame
merkel en s'appuyant sur le parlement
fait manque en fait
et est ce que je vous dis là c'est que
du coup comment gère-t-on
intergouvernementales et que ce qu'il
faut parlement européen est minoré les
élections européennes
il représente à rien certes agences de
placement pour pré retraités jeunes
loups etc ou à faire de la communication
avec des candidats qu'on estime tenir le
haut du pavé
parce que les attirer kenyan martin
s'est produit j'ai encore une fois c'est
pas énorme a atteint c'est un excellent
syndicaliste bon il dit qu'il n'est pas
candidat mais quand vous passez à la
télé pour dire ça c'est que vous êtes
candidat donc il a envie de faire la
politique c'est très bien pour lui et
c'est très bien qu'un syndicaliste
harry sur sur la scène publique le
problème après tout problème n'est pas
là le problème c'est que enfin moi je
n'aime pas parler de moi mais là j'ai en
charge du gros rapport du parlement
européen sur l'action de la troïka
je l'aï fait un cac expliquez nous donc
c'est louis commission européenne et
banque centrale qui m'est assez
reviendrait à les programmes
d'assistance
oui les plans dead eye irlande à chypre
à la grèce et au portugal
donc comme cette action est assez
controversé sur le terrain et qu'il ya
un vrai problème de légitimité
démocratique le parlement européen a
obtenu un rapport d' enquête
et comme c'est la seule institution élue
au suffrage universel c'est important
qu'elles puissent donner de la voix
parce que nos concitoyens s'interrogent
notamment avant les élections
européennes
il aligne donc en avait la charge et
donc moi j'ai la charge de ce rapport là
avec le ppe marc aras ai-je été impliqué
dans d'autres rapports qui invite à un
changement de traité pour rendre
l'europe plus démocratique et pour
donner plus de pouvoir justement
parlement le ps n'a pas reconnu ce
travail de votre part mais ça pose un
problème parce que nous on est au front
en première ligne sur le pacte de
stabilité sur les 3 % oui mais on a
notamment à ce que le parti socialiste
reconnaisse ce travail là est ce que
votre maison reconnaît ce travail moi je
regrette que
je n'ai pas d'appui public plus plus
plus plus fermes sur cette question là
parce que ça ça décrit didier sa part
dans ça décrédibilise au bout d'un
moment ça délégitime ce qu on fait quoi
et vous quelle est votre position par
rapport à votre parti vous y êtes
engagés depuis le début des années 90 je
crois est ce que vous comptez le quitter
non pour que voulait que je quitte non
après tout la vous n'avez pas été
reconduits sur les listes que comment
est ce que vous allez rebondir après ça
et continuer à exercer mon métier libre
aux deux penseurs après après ce que
vous voulez vous réengager dans la
sphère publique sur un autre type de
mandat par exemple c'est possible c'est
possible parce que la légitimité du
suffrage universel fait que vous avez un
porte-voix plus important que quand vous
êtes professeur savants cosinus à
l'université bon l'intérêt c'est ça
c'est c'est d'avoir une légitimité dans
le débat public
après j'espère que dans mon parti ça va
évoluer parce que beaucoup de gens sont
choqués par ce qui s'est passé mais le
disent pas beau après je vous rassure ce
n'est pas l'apanage du parti socialiste
seulement c'est aussi ce qui se passe
dans notre parti les manques donc merci
d'avoir été avec nous nous on continue
dans la partie magazine de cette
émission direction l'espagne en
andalousie plus précisément là bas
depuis quelques temps si vous êtes un
riche investisseur étranger on peut vous
offrir un visa de résidence moyennant
finance c'est un reportage de fleurs à
sauvage
il n'y a pas que le climat qui attire
les étrangers fortunés en espagne il ya
aussi les visas doré depuis octobre 2013
le gouvernement espagnol offre aux
investisseurs étrangers un visa de
résident permanent contre un achat
immobilier de 500000 euros minimum
asphyxiés par la crise des dettes
publiques les pays du sud de l'europe
sont prêts à tout pour trouver de
l'argent frais d'autant que la bulle
immobilière en espagne a laissé un stock
considérable de logements vacants
millions d'âmes laisse partir
l'espagne a aujourd'hui un million de
logements vides issue de la crise
immobilière
pendant les années 2000 et jusqu'en 2008
on a construit près de cent mille
logements par an donc ça a créé un stock
énorme de logements que les espagnols ne
peuvent pas acheter surtout à ces prix
là donc l'une des solutions pour écouler
ses stocks
c'est de proposer ces logements aux
étrangers fortunés en leur donnant en
échange des visa de résidence
à marbella en andalousie
un tiers des habitants sont de
nationalité étrangère avec ses 325 jours
de soleil par an la ville a toujours
attiré les touristes étrangers
alors bonjour wacom vient de chanter je
suis stephen owen et sa femme habite
shenzhen en chine
ils font partie de la jeunesse dorée
chinoise ce matin ils ont rendez-vous
pour l'achat d'un logement à marbella
avec steven qui est agent immobilier
voici les projets que nous allons
visiter aujourd'hui celui ci est
idéalement placé sur le golden 1000 les
prix vont de six cent mille euros à plus
d'un million dans cette résidence de jeu
la raison pour laquelle je veux acheter
une propriété ici c'est que je cherche
un endroit où passer mes vacances à 29
ans par wayne possède déjà une propriété
en australie chefs d'entreprise en chine
il espère que l'achat de ce logement lui
permettra ensuite de faire du business
en europe
je pense que l'économie en europe se
développe et il y a donc beaucoup
d'opportunités en termes
d'investissements ici puis en plus
l'espagne a une bonne équipe de foot
dans cette agence immobilière on a
constaté depuis la mise en place des
visas doré un fort intérêt chez la
clientèle étrangère
on reçoit une trentaine de demandes
d'informations par jour beaucoup
viennent d'asie du moyen-orient
ils demandent tous comment fonctionne la
loi en fait ils ne veulent pas
s'installer en espagne ni payer leurs
impôts ici car ils veulent rester dans
leur pays tout en ayant la possibilité
de se déplacer facilement en europe
présentation faite direction la
résidence de luxe lomas del rei miguel
va leur faire le tour du propriétaire
sur 85 appartements il en reste 18 à
vendre 3 piscine une salle de gym et
bientôt un sauna pour satisfaire les
habitants pouvaient me donner la surface
pour cet appartement alors ici nous
avons 125 m² la terrasse elle mesure 55
m² et le jardin à peu près 75 m² le
jacuzzi est inclus dans le prix incite
la télévision aujourd'hui à marbella la
clientèle change de profil c'est vrai
que le nombre de clients qui viennent
d'angleterre ou d'allemagne diminue
c'était des gens qui investissaient dans
un logement pour leur retraite
aujourd'hui ce sont surtout des clients
russes ou chinois qui viennent
et en plus ce sont de jeunes couples
si les visas dorées font le bonheur des
agents immobiliers sur le front de mer
de marbella
la mesure fait débat oui moi ça me va
bien je trouve ça bien parce que ici ils
vont dépenser de l'argent ça ne me
paraît pas bien qu'on puisse acheter un
visa juste parce qu'on est riche en plus
il y en a qui vont venir ici blanchir
leur argent et à gauche de l'échiquier
politique on refuse la marchandisation
du permis de résidence procès antonio
garcia rubio du parti de la gauche unie
dénoncent une mesure discriminatoire
nous mettons des frontières
infranchissables à ceuta et mellila pour
que ceux qui viennent d'afrique ne
puisse pas entrer en espagne
et puis il y à des tragédies comme à
lampedusa
mais s'il immigrants est riche et qu'il
a cinq cent mille euros investir alors
là il n'y a plus de problème ça montre
le cynisme des autorités européennes qui
sont intéressés par les immigrants
fortune et qu'ils viennent ici pour
spéculer ou juste pour profiter du
système jusqu'à présent bruxelles n'a
pas pris position sur la question des
visas doré
car la délivrance des permis de
résidence relève entièrement des états
membres même si avec ces visas de ré les
étrangers non européens ont accès aux 26
pays de l'espace schengen
voilà alors que doit-on faire face à la
recrudescence de ces visas doré que ce
soit en espagne au portugal à malte ou
encore à chypre eh bien je reçois deux
députés avec moi sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui bonjour philippe juvin vous
êtes des européens français membre du
parti populaire européen et de l'ump et
rui tavares vous êtes portugais et vous
êtes membre du groupe des verts c'est à
vous que s'adresse la première question
le portugal donne aussi ce type de visa
doré finalement dans un pays en crise
est ce que ce n'est pas une bonne
solution pour sortir un petit peu du
marasme économique
je crois que vous avez là l'explication
de cette politique des visas devrait en
effet au portugal on a une loi qui est
quasiment la même que la loi espagnole
c'est à dire à partir des demi million
d'euros 1 dans un achat immobilier vous
pouvez avoir un visa doré l'explication
que le gouvernement a donné pour cette
politique pour ces lois a été qu on
aurait plus d'emploi plus
d'investissements au portugal plus du
sinn des compagnies en effet après la la
les premières des années de la politique
de visas doré au portugal il n'y a pas
eu un seul poste de travail qu'on puisse
prouver qu a été créée par passé
politique des visas doré on ne fait pas
des questions
donc les investisseurs qui viennent si
vous avez donc 1 510 euros à dépenser
dans un appartement à lisbonne
on n'a pas eu une boule de l'immobilier
aussi grande que l'espagnol mais quand
même il n'y en a beaucoup pour
pin rouge choisir au portugal en termes
de mobilier vous aviez envisagé étant le
ministre de l'économie portugaise a dit
que enfin signalé qu'ils avaient quand
même 242 millions d'euros qui avaient
été investis sur le territoire portugais
en l'espace de deux ans d'existence le
portugal est un pays qui a des problèmes
budgétaires c'est à dire l'état
portugais le gouvernement cherche coûte
que brit air est bien celle baptisée
l'ailé car les eaux millions d'euros
quand même ces camps nazis sommes donc
est ce que finalement on peut se
permettre de cracher si je peux dire
assure dans le roman plusieurs problèmes
lorsque parce que on ne fait pas on
n'enregistre pas là l'origine de cet
argent il ya beaucoup de blanchiment
d'argent
par exemple on a des visages aubry
attribués à des citoyen de la
guinée-bissau et on sait bien que la
guinée bissau mali est un pays qui est
pris par le parent narco par le
narcotrafic et c'est le même pays ou ont
maintenant on a interrompu la seule le
seul vol qui avait entre bissau et
l'europe qui était le bisso lisbonne
parce qu'on a beaucoup de problèmes de
demandeurs d'asile il y inclut syrien et
aussi de l'immigration illégale venus de
la guinée bissau
c'est à dire on ne laisse pas entrer les
10 en guinée un pauvre mais on les sent
très seule et ceux qui volent légué les
bissau-guinéens pauvres c'est à dire si
nous étions général la guinée bissau et
vous fait des affaires avec les
narcotrafiquants colombiens et que vous
voler les ressources naturelles
naturelles la guinée bissau et vous
voler le peuple la guinée bissau qui ne
peut pas rentrer au portugal
là vous pouvez rentrer au portugal vous
achetez un visa doré qui est perpétuelle
et on a on a des cas beaucoup de cadres
de guinée-bissau angola et l'autre
problème qui est un problème européen
c'est que ça a déclenché une espèce de
compétition entre les pays européens
pour offrir des cordes et des meilleures
conditions aux étrangers qui veulent
acheter des visas envers dont on l'a le
cas de malte qui vont assurément val
d'azun et minières philippe juvin quand
on est un pays en crise et la plupart
des pays qui offrent ces golden visa le
son est ce qu'on a les moyens de se
passer de cette manne financière
d'abord je crois qu'on a les moyens
d'affirmer qu'il ya des choses qui ne se
vendent pas
nationalité ne se vend pas je sais que
on a l'exemple qui est aujourd'hui celui
de malte où on explique qu'il est
presque facile d'obtenir une nationalité
en payant ça c'est inacceptable parce
que malte en fête propose carrément la
nationalité la houle et pas plus de
visas voilà comme dans le reportage et
on parle de nationalité ça c'est
inacceptable
la deuxième chose inacceptable c'est que
la technique la procédure une facilité
super supplémentaires avoir un fisac
quand on a de l'argent que quand on n'a
pas ça c'est inacceptable également et
je partage
là-dessus la vie de mon voisin en
revanche je trouve qu'il n'est pas
illogique que quelqu'un qui arrive en
disant moi je peux investir 10 20 30 100
millions d'euros dans votre pays qu'on
lui fasse on le fasse profiter d'une
procédure qui lui permettent d'obtenir
un visa de tourisme servira visa
temporaire ce qui n'a rien à voir si
vous offre les manifs à 6,6 alors la
difficulté elle est là vous avez raison
quand j'entre dans un pays de l'espace
schengen j'entre dans tous les pays de
l'espace schengen
je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait une
réflexion au niveau européen en se
disant qu'au fond ce qu'ils veulent
appliquer cette politique est encore une
fois vous l'avais dit dans le reportage
ce sont les états qui le décide c'est
pas l'europe si les états décident
d'appliquer une telle procédure
il faut qu'on se mette d'accord au plan
européen et probablement ces gens-là
sorte de schengen et bien alors
justement il ya un des intervenants de
reportages qu'il y avait une question
directe à vous poser dans les coupes
pour quesnoy appris à ne pas développer
ce type de visa et un territoire
schengen parce que dans ce cas c'est que
cela bénéficierait à tous le monde
ratage
d'abord c'est aux états de décider
qu'ils acceptent sur leur territoire
c'est comme ça et aujourd'hui l'europe
est organisée avec un droit de la
nationalité qui est d'ordre national le
deuxième point c'est que la difficulté
c'est qu'un certain nombre de ces visas
doré vous avez décrit conduisent c'est
ainsi la loi nationale a décidé
automatiquement la nationalité ou
tellement automatiquement que finalement
la nasa ut arrive au bout un parler
également de la lettonie
donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas de mot génie
des choses et moi en tant que citoyen
français et citoyens européens
je refuse l'idée que quelqu'un
deviennent citoyens européens parce
qu'il a payé ça ça me paraît impossible
contraire à toute notre histoire
européenne
mais par exemple monsieur tavarez après
tout si tous les pays d'europe en fait
permettait un espèce de visa de séjour
comme ça ça éviterait en fait les
concurrences entre pays est ce que ça
pourrait pas être une piste pour
clarifier les choses moi je crois que
quelqu'un un entrepreneur qui achètent
une usine en europe il faut bien lui
criait des facilités pour visiter son
jeu son nous il n'y a pas de risque que
met la main de joie mais il faut faire
la même chose aussi pour d'autres
personnes
par exemple quand je vois les
universités au portugal en espagne qui
veulent faire des déclics veulent
recevoir des scientifiques brésiliens ou
du maghreb par exemple on a beaucoup de
problèmes avec les chercheurs de ma
crème aussi à cause des des lois après
le 11 septembre en europe et c'est aussi
inacceptable c'est à dire on a aussi
besoin de chercher où on pourrait crier
des visas aussi pour les artistes on
peut on peut penser à une série de
catégorie dans le cadre d'une réforme
générale des politiques d'une
immigration asile et réfugiés en europe
parce que là ce qui est quand même assez
cynique effectivement et c'est bien ce
qui est dit dans le reportage c'est que
d'un autre côté on laisse en fait des
centaines de d'étrangers en fait
s'échouer sur les plages de lampedusa
sans rien faire on parlait de ceuta et
mellila donc les deux enclaves
espagnoles qui voit également des
centaines de réfugiés venir s'écraser
sur les barbelés tous les jours il ya eu
une forme de cynisme un petit peu là
dedans d'accueillir abritant il faut pas
confondre
on est sur plusieurs sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir d'un côté la nationalité on
ne peut pas acquérir la chaîne était en
payant ça il faut que ce soit clair mais
c'est par la banalisation n'est pas que
ce n'est pas clair mais la nativité
c'est pas clair si la présidente vous
pouvez le deuxième point après il ya le
design
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
visas qui ne conduisent pas la
nationalité dès lors vous apportez vous
avez à l'image de ce que fait elle est
d'un vert d'investisseurs économique ou
intellectuelles jeu un chercheur qui
vient éclairer la recherche européenne
par son savoir je trouve que normal que
l'europe lui facilite les choses
il va pas faire la queue pendant cinq
mois pour avoir un visa alors qu'il
vient nous aider et participer à notre
aventure intellectuelle
donc la difficulté il faut définir des
critères au niveau européen mais ces
critères nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui
défini c'est ça le souci alors rude à
farès vous évoquez tout à l'heure la
question du blanchiment
comment être certain aujourd'hui au sein
de l'europe
de la venue en fait de ses capitaux et
la légalité si je puis dire de ces
quatre temps on peut être être certain
si on cherche si on fouille c'était
c'est à dire je sais qu'au portugal il
ya plusieurs cadres de blanchiment
d'argent qui sont aux tribunaux au
portugal de la part des généraux
angolais par exemple l'engueulade fait
des pays qui est un pays de langue
portugaise qui est donc les les généraux
angolais qui ont accès aux hauts revenus
des diamants de pétrole hahn on voit la
connaissent bien le portugal il s'est
levé où ils ont leurs enfants qui
étudient et c'est donc il ya une façon
de faire les choses qui est la bonne
c'est à dire il faut vérifier d'où vient
cet argent il mais il ya la façon dont
elle est en train d'être fait maintenant
c'est à dire on ne cherche pas on ne
veut pas savoir
et pourtant c'est très bien et ça c'est
un problème pour l'europe parce que
c'est vrai que la nationalité les visas
c'est une question d etat mais il faut
aussi compter avec les conséquences
européenne de ces décisions là d'une
part on n'a pas parlé par exemple
d'embellie la hongrie la hongrie
maintenant donne la nationalité a
beaucoup de descendants dont trois dans
les pays autour d'eux et de la hongrie
où il y avait il y avait des territoires
hongrois avant la première guerre
mondiale
mais on sait par exemple que des
milliers de serbes ont demandé la
nationalité hongroise
après avoir fait quelques cours dont on
croit qu'ils ont une très rapide
automatiquement la nationalité par ce
moyen là ils ont accès en droit de vente
en droit de vote qui en france dans les
élections parle parle bobo parlement
européen et dans les élections
gouvernementales et les gouvernements
des états membres de l'union sont au
conseil
donc c'est à dire il ya des conséquences
à européen après il y a une conséquence
sur la question de la confiance
réciproque entre les tribunaux européens
c'est-à-dire le statut d'une entreprise
change quand elle est détenue par un
européen
si vous donnez leur nationalité à un
européen je vous interromps vous êtes
d'accord que
la capacité à définir les règles comme
quand on devient portugais italiens
espagnols français doit rester dans les
mains de l'état où l état membre ça ne
peut pas être une gestion déléguée à
l'union enfin nous nommons groupe
politique le ppe sommes très attachés à
ce que la nation est un sens qu'ils
soient définies au niveau national bon
écoute et messieurs en attendant on vous
mettra peut-être pas d'accord sur cette
question de qui doit définir la
nationalité ou pas malheureusement c'est
la fin de notre débat on continuera sur
cette question je vous assure merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis rendez
vous la semaine prochaine à bruxelles
avec ahmed tazir bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
je vous demande de répondre oui